hey everyone happy Forza launch and I'm
so excited because inside of here is a
custom Forza Xbox I I think it is they
said they were sending one but there's
no branding on the outside so we're
going to have to open it up and check it
out I feel like this year I've done so
much with Forza so it's super exciting
that the game is actually out you can
play it on Game Pass as well I went up
to Seattle earlier this year to reveal
the cover cars which is the Cadillac vs
series. R race car and the Chevrolet
Corvette eay which is the first electric
Corvette I also got to post a video
checking out the Corvette eay and very
very soon I'm going to be posting a
video getting a chance to finally Drive
the eay which spoiler alert it was
really fun you also may have seen this
video that I posted the other day it's
uh it was supposed to be a short but it
was too long for a short so I just ended
up posting the entire Vlog as a vertical
video here on YouTube we went to a
driving school with Forza in Vegas at
the Spring Mountain Resort we got a
chance to drive the Corvette Stingray
all around the track and we did like a
little mini driver school and it was so
so awesome I having so much fun making
car content and I've never really made
much car stuff in the past so kind of
getting into this whole new world
there's so much to learn but man I'm
obsessed anyway let's unbox the Xbox and
see what's
inside here it is here it
is oh my oh man I okay for some reason I
was thinking it was going to be the eay
but this is so sick it's the Cadillac
v.r theme oh you're beautiful you are so
pretty holy moly this is amazing oh wow
this is so cool we've also got a
controller the controller's even
custom dude I am just so shook and as
you may have noticed another controller
just fell over I got this one in Vegas
you can make custom color controllers to
The Design Lab so they gave us this one
and since I've got the Cadillac here
they also did an eay elite controller
just beautiful I'll show you guys those
in a second here's the Xbox they've got
all of the little accents it looks so so
good here's the
front here's the other side love it love
it so much here's the controller check
that out it's got this little Cadillac
racing mhm and here's a closer look at
the yellow Design Lab
controller
and the eay elite wow this one just
looks absolutely
stunning I've also got the custom
joystick Toppers as well that you can
custom color those and the case also has
a custom Xbox logo it's pretty cool
because you can basically customize
these controllers to be almost any color
you want and I love you can now also
Custom Design the elite controllers
because I love the elite controller well
thank you guys for watching this was
just a very short quick video cuz I
wanted to show you guys this Xbox and I
wanted to unbox it and also remind you
that Forza is available on Game Pass if
you do have Game Pass and it is
currently out for Xbox and PC so I've
already been playing it so I definitely
plan on doing some streams so if you'd
be interested in that let me know and
with that my friends I'll see you guys
in the next video bye